[Applaudissements]
8h13 sur Europe 1 votre invité ce matin
Sony Mabrouk et la secrétaire d'État
chargée de la jeunesse et du service
national universel bienvenue sur Europe
1 et bonjour Sarah Hery bonjour elle
vous dit merci
qui dit merci un grand merci
qui dit merci vous ne voyez pas
qui peut dire merci ce matin
Marine Le Pen bien sûr elle vous
remercie tous et en particulier le
président de la République de
reconnaître publiquement que le cordon
sanitaire n'existe plus elle a raison de
vous dire merci franchement ça c'est les
anathèmes des petits coups de manchette
moi ce que je vois c'est que notre
gouvernement est assez pragmatique
aujourd'hui c'est quoi notre priorité
c'est le quotidien des Français là vous
nous fait de la langue de bois mais
absolument pas clairement Emmanuel
Macron a fait du fait que les arguments
moraux font chier et que le fameux
Cardon sanitaire a cédé depuis longtemps
vous êtes d'accord nous soyons très
clair comment lutte contre le Front
national comment on lutte national
comment lutte contre l'extrême droite
dans notre pays et bien en allant
chercher des solutions quand on installe
des usines quand rien industrialise
quand on a on va chercher 8000 emplois
supplémentaires 1,2 millions d'emplois
ça aide qui les ouvriers les employés
sur les terres ou l'extrême droite a
raison et vous savez moi je veux dire
lutter aujourd'hui contre les extrêmes
parce que pour moi lutter contre
l'extrême droite comme lutter contre
l'extrême gauche mettez sur le même plan
moi j'ai toujours sur le même plan la
lutte contre les extrêmes parce que les
deux fractures chacun sa manière chacun
à sa méthode c'est vrai mais dans le
fond lutter contre ces extrêmes c'est
aller chercher l'essence même de
casquettes français être français c'est
avoir foi dans le mérite c'est avoir une
politique qui va chercher de la justice
mais vous mettez sur le même plan ça
râlerait pour ce show bien de bien
d'accord extrême gauche je vous
laisserai qui frappe à vos yeux
rassemblement national et France
insoumis ce qui fracture notre pays je
lutterai toujours contre quelle que soit
la forme quel que soit la forme pourquoi
parce que je suis profondément
universaliste parce que je crois que la
politique elle apporte des solutions ces
solutions elles doivent avoir deux
piliers le mérite l'effort la foi dans
nos institutions et de l'autre côté
l'espérance pour ces enfants pour son
travail pour sa famille pour sa santé et
ses deux piliers on a des mesures
concrètes on va en parler quelle est la
définition pour vous ce matin du mot
désaveu recadrage ou bien même
humiliation vous savez moi je suis pas
agrégé
hier en conseil des ministres Emmanuel
Macron rempli en rappelant à l'ordre
Elizabeth borne quant à sa sortie sur le
et Pétain reprendre ainsi publiquement
sa première mise comment vous appelez
cela alors je vous vois je sais pas où
est-ce que vous avez vu que c'était
public moi il se trouve qu'on m'a
toujours appris et c'est le fruit de
l'éducation qui a été la mienne de ne
jamais commander des propos quand tu as
pas été témoin de ses propos il se
trouve que hier matin
en Italie vous pensez que le Président
de la République n'a pas prononcé ces
mots moi je moi je fais pas de
supputation hier moi je m'occupais des
dictionnaire des synonymes recadrage
blâme prise de distance humiliation
qu'est-ce que vous choisissez aucune
c'est un salut à sa sortie
c'est action collective pour le pour le
quotidien des Français pour retrouver la
fierté de notre pays pour rester dans le
concert des nations rien ne va plus
quand une première ministre s'exaspère
ainsi un président qu'attend-il pour la
remplacer pourquoi l'user ainsi jusqu'à
la corde mais la confiance est là
aujourd'hui elle est première entre le
prochain grand public et la première
ministre aujourd'hui elle est la chef de
notre gouvernement vous n'y croyez même
pas elle est c'est faux aujourd'hui elle
est la chef de notre gouvernement c'est
elle qui siège aux questions au
gouvernement
du président de la République et
exclusivement de la présence et vous
savez moi je suis tellement Gauliste que
j'adore notre Constitution il se trouve
qu'elle sera les rôles les
responsabilités sont rappelés noir sur
blanc mais jamais je m'amuserai à
rentrer dans des débats c'est 3 minutes
qu'on commande
des mots potentiellement dit pendant un
conseil des ministres moi ce que je veux
dire c'est que au quotidien les Français
ils me disent quoi je veux je veux un
métier je veux accéder au logement je
veux accéder aux soins je veux que donc
sur le fond un avenir il faut arrêter
les arguments moraux contre le
rassemblement national vous dites oui il
faut répondre aux moyens sont
nécessaires pour lutter contre tous les
moyens y compris de dire que c'est des
repères vous pensez que les repères
historiques ne sont pas naisses alors
vous pensez est-ce que vous pensez que
le rassemblement national est l'héritier
de Pétain moi je pense que aujourd'hui
plus que jamais nous avons besoin
d'avoir conscience de notre histoire des
courants historiques qui ont bâti notre
histoire parce qu'on ne peut pas bâtir
un avenir si on n'a pas consommé pas mal
et c'est pour ça que très basiquement en
tant que citoyenne je pense que il faut
muscler l'esprit de nos citoyens avec
évidemment toutes les idéologies qui ont
pu traverser notre pays mais surtout
répondre aux besoins maintenant à ce
moment et dénoncer les facéties ça veut
dire quoi quand le rassemblement
national ne vote pas au niveau européen
un certain nombre de soutiens pour les
Français mais il faut le dire c'est
gonflé quand même de la part d'un
gouvernement qui a celui encore quelques
semaines l'attitude républicaine du
rassemblement national lors du débat sur
la réforme des retraites et aujourd'hui
même il y a que la première ministre qui
dit que c'est l'héritier
en même temps est-ce qu'il n'a pas des
limites madame Mabrouk nous avons
toujours combattu et l'extrême droite et
l'extrême gauche de manière assez ferme
pour plein de raisons la première c'est
parce que les deux veulent fracturer
notre pays l'extrême droite c'est le
fruit c'est ça a été une des raisons qui
a fait que je me suis engagée en
politique pourquoi parce qu'il ne me
regarde pas de la même manière qu'un
autre français donc je ne veux pas qu'on
me juge sur mon degré de français ça ça
a été un des enjeux qui a été le mien
pourquoi parce que moi je crois au
mérite je crois à la force de cette
France qui te regarde simplement par
l'effort et le tien et tes actes ça
c'est important pour moi et de l'autre
côté une extrême gauche qui appelle à
l'anarchie au désordre et finalement à
détruire tout ce qu'on a comme grand
pilier d'autorité dans notre pays et ça
c'est aussi mon combat donc dans le fond
vous me trouverez toujours dans la lutte
contre les extrêmes l'extrême droite en
premier et l'extrême droite qui suit
parce qu'en plus ça pullule sur mon
territoire vous avez dit aimer la
Constitution tout à l'heure je vais
finir sur ce sujet vous aimez peut-être
aussi des références cinématographiques
comme les tontons flingueurs il lui a
montré qui sert Raoul on l'a retrouvé
par pays façon puzzle 4 coins de Paris
il correctionne plus le Président il
disperse d'accord présent de la
République il donne un glap et je crois
qu'il fait la fierté en réalité d'un
grand pays qui est le nôtre et plus on
fait attention à ce qu'on dit sur d'une
certaine manière des grandes
institutions et je pense que plus on
fait grandir la France je vois Dimitri
souris je crois qu'il n'a pas apprécié
mon mon accent il y a mieux pour faire
les tontons flingueurs allez-y
intervenez dans l'interview droit
d'envoyer le bruitage bon sur le fond
dans l'actualité la proposition de loi
du groupe liotte Sarah pour abroger la
réforme des retraites arrive en
commission aujourd'hui une proposition
qui a folle la majorité et le
gouvernement qu'il a jugent
anticonstitutionnel hier le président
soumis de la commission des finances et
Coquerel a jugé recevable mais de quoi
vous avez peur du débat on est en débat
permanent madame Mabrouk entre le grand
débat le CNR les rencontres à Matignon
l'été priorité ta voix enfin on peut pas
dire que on est un gouvernement qui ne
débat pas une majorité qui débat puisque
les débats sont non-stop à l'Assemblée
nationale je rappelle juste quand même
pour nos auditeurs qui a fui le débat
pendant la réforme des retraites c'est
l'extrême gauche qui a posé des
amendements pour changer des virgules
c'est l'extrême gauche donc moi je veux
bien qu'on nous fasse toutes les leçons
mais comme vous savez je ne
parlementaire nez j'adore j'adore
l'Assemblée nationale j'ai appris à
aimer et à comprendre le Sénat donc je
m'amuserai même pas une seconde à aller
faire la leçon sur comment devrait se
passer ce texte
comme Charles de Courson qui est devenu
votre dit-on votre premier reposant
aujourd'hui qui parle de dérive
autoritaire d'un parlement bafoué et
même d'un gouvernement qui pourrait
tomber qu'est-ce qu'il incarne à vos
yeux c'est triste parce que Charles
m'aider de Courson il est le fruit et
l'héritier d'une partie de ma famille
politique c'est un EDF il s'est perdu
écoutez que ce que je me dis ça peut
arriver à tout le monde après des
décennies à l'Assemblée nationale bon
c'était mon collègue en commission des
finances je ne reconnais plus ses propos
alors que c'était un homme de raison
construit très combatif il a toujours
été mais là je le comprends plus après
parce qu'il se pose à la réforme
pas du tout je fais pas référence à la
réforme des retraites exclusivement
c'est par ça a commencé d'abord avec la
question du passé anitaire ça a commencé
quand il a quitté son groupe historique
pour aller dans le groupe plus haute ça
a quand même été un mouvement qui a pris
maintenant quelques quelques années mais
au-delà du cas particulier de de Charles
Amédée de Courson moi j'ai profondément
franchement confiance dans les députés
qui trouveront les moyens elle est au
vote elle est jaune
du gouvernement et vous savez madame
au-delà du fait que je ne commenterai
pas les les moyens possibles pour faire
ou pas faire ce vote je sais une chose
j'ai conscience d'une chose il ne faut
pas laisser imaginer aux Français qu'il
y a des choses qui ne sont pas
démocratiques toutes les mesures toutes
les mesures toutes les positions quand
quand Eric Coquerel fait le choix d'une
décision politique vous avez vu tout ce
qui a été dit sur lui hier par la
majorité j'ai vu bien sûr j'ai vu
évidemment je m'intéresse mais vous
savez moi ça a pas été mon président de
commission on présente Commission a été
Éric verte à l'époque qui était dans
l'opposition
c'est incompréhensible cette série
recevabilité maintenant ça a été ça
décision les autres députés sont pas
moins légitimes pour utiliser les outils
de notre assemblée et donc pourquoi des
mesures seraient plus légitimes que
d'autres alors laissons les
parlementaires entre représentants du
peuple de France
décidé quel sera le sort de cette
proposition vous êtes en charge de la
jeunesse et du service national
universel le SMU qui est mis en place à
rappelons l'expérimenté depuis 2019 on
voit en parler mais d'abord vous étiez
hier à Rome pour l'élaboration d'un
d'une sorte de service civique
franco-italien mais de quoi s'agit-il
traiter du kirinal un traité historique
entre la France et l'Italie vous savez
moi je crois que quand il y a des
peuples frères il faut construire des
liens mais des liens forts diplomatiques
en ce moment entre ces peuples frères
sont compliqués
moi j'ai toujours cru qu'il fallait
enraciner plus en profondeur les
relations entre des peuples au-delà
évidemment des actualités
gouvernementales qui nécessitent parfois
beaucoup de dialogues beaucoup de
pédagogie vous en parle vous parlez
beaucoup aussi du SNU évidemment vous
êtes en charge de cela avec une
évolution et la mise en place de classe
d'engagement je le dis à nos auditeurs
c'est une nouvelle formule sur la base
du volontariat des enseignants dans le
cadre de séjour de 12 jours pour les
lycéens avec un encadrement partagé
entre personnel de l'éducation et des
anciens militaires d'abord est-ce que
c'est en bonne voie c'est un très bonne
voie et c'est même c'est même plus que
ça les séjours de juin et de juillet
dépassent toutes nos espérances on a une
liste d'attente de plusieurs milliers de
jeunes qui souhaitent aller alors là
c'est vraiment le coup de l'extrême
droite l'extrême gauche qui a essayé de
elle vous réagissent de faire entrer
l'armée à l'école de vouloir militariser
la genèse des excès des excès la
tyrannie d'une minorité bruyante rien
d'autre ceux qui ont vu le projet ceux
qui ont été et ceux qui ont discuté avec
des jeunes qui l'ont fait en réalité
adhère et viennent au point où on a plus
de jeunes volontaires à ce projet que de
place ce qui nous amène évidemment à
trouver d'autres modèles certains
mettent en cause justement cet
engouement et ses chiffres vous savez
aujourd'hui le doute il est permis moi
ce que je vois c'est des familles qui
qui du coup appellent à ce que leurs
enfants participent et j'en suis
particulièrement fier parce que ça veut
dire quoi c'est des jeunes qui viennent
pendant leurs vacances scolaires prendre
du temps qu'il les viendrapeau qui
vivent un temps de cohésion
à l'école du patriotisme ça peut être
une réponse à la décibilisation dans
l'une des réponses dont tu as parlé
manuel Macron c'est une chance pour les
jeunes pour le pays bien sûr c'est une
chance c'est une chance pour le jeûne et
c'est une chance pour la France pour
deux raisons la première c'est que pour
faire nation on a besoin de se respecter
on a besoin de d'avoir conscience de la
grandeur de notre héritage on a besoin
de vivre moi je crois à la force du
rituel et ces rituels c'est quoi se
lever le matin dormir dans un dortoir
avec peut-être quelqu'un qu'on ne
connaît pas d'un autre milieu social
d'un autre territoire qui vient d'un
territoire c'est aussi les ordres etc et
certains disent que justement c'était
militarisation d'une partie de la
société
basique de du discours d'ultra gauche
classique antimilitariste moi ce que je
vois c'est des hommes et des femmes qui
ont servi nos armées qui ont servi nos
drapeaux qu'ils soient pompiers ou
militaires des enseignants et des gens
qui viennent du monde associatif qui
mettent leurs efforts et leurs
connaissances en commun pour notre
jeunesse quand on voit les défis qui
nous attendent aujourd'hui devant eux je
pense évidemment aux questions
démocratiques je pense évidemment à la
guerre qui est durant Ukraine je pense
même à cette dislocation de notre
société enfin la réalité elle est là
comment tu vas chercher de l'unité et
bien en allant donner les moyens à cette
jeunesse d'avoir conscience en cas sa
capacité de faire justement qu'il faut
de la Transformer il y a 80 ans en 1943
a été créé le champ des partisans
devenus chant emblématique de la
résistance un chant entonné par deux
nombreux volontaires du SNU écoute on
[Musique]
ça participe de la transmission bien sûr
transmission
héritage transcendance pourquoi parce
que quand on chante le chant des
partisans quand on chante la
Marseillaise ensemble et bien on fait
communauté on fait communauté nationale
et moi ça me fait toujours de l'émotion
quand je vois des jeunes de 16 ans
Anthony et la Marseillaise et le chant
des partisans alors même que certains
récents certains récurent alors certains
ricanes et aussi vous avez été cible de
beaucoup de n'ont pas de critiques Sarah
oui vous dites oui vous êtes faites
partie de la vous êtes benjamine du
gouvernement je crois avec Gabriel Attal
vous n'avez pas froid aux yeux quand il
s'agit de différents sujets vous avez
été même si c'est la sphère privée mais
vous l'avez dit publiquement la première
ministre femme a déclaré publiquement en
tous les cassant son homosexualité tout
ça fait partie d'un tout c'est une
manière de faire de la politique il y a
plusieurs choses différentes la première
c'est moi je ne serai jamais partie des
lâches de ceux qui mèneront pas les
combats nécessaires pour que notre pays
reste fort et prépare nos jeunesses dans
leur diversité à aller trouver les voies
et moyens pour de construire notre pays
par contre ma vie privée je l'ai jamais
mis en public maintenant quand vous
répondez à une question sur la violence
des réseaux sociaux et que vous dites
que ça fait de la peine à m'accompagne
ça fait un titre dans l'article web ça
ne fait pas le même titre dans l'article
papier dans le fond c'est une manière
médiatique de traiter le sujet mais si
ça a permis à une jeune fille de parler
à ses parents et bien c'est une chance
merci Sarah Eric très bonne journée à
vous merci à vous et restez avec nous
Gaspard Proust arrive dans un instant il
va nous rejoindre
des partisans et les tontons flingueurs
dans la même interview il y a de la
matière un petit peu